in some ways i was
pleased in some ways i was
a little frightened
to bring up
um
the experiences and i'll be perfectly
honest i had a lot of anxiety coming
here today
though i have read this book and a
number of times read undaunted valor 719
quite a few times i've earmarked it
i've read after action reports on it
that
hopefully matt and he did he had some of
these uh after-action reports
uh that he took his data from
um
but still sitting here uh
now
and talking about it with you
and you weren't there
uh i could talk about somebody that was
there
and uh
but
and not have anxiety but
you weren't there
and
i often wonder
i'm telling you this
but what are you actually hearing
because you weren't there
and you can tell me about what you did
and i can listen to it but i wasn't
there
and so there's a difference
yeah yeah there's
there's always going to be a little gap
or a big gap depending on you know the
person's experiences
and
you know
what one thing i think is interesting
about you when you start talking about
coming home and what you're going
through
i think the one thing that's good is
if people actually understand
what they're feeling a little bit and i
remember like you get a new guy that's
overseas
and i'd look at a new guy that's
overseas now you could tell they're
nervous right
and
you know just say something like hey man
you're you know that feeling you get in
your stomach and they'd be like
you know trying not to tell you but then
they'd admit to it yeah and i go yeah
you're just nervous it's your it's your
body getting ready to go fight it's
totally normal that's what you should
feel like
and they'd be like oh okay oh you oh by
the way you won't be able to sleep
tonight because we gotta operation
tomorrow you're not gonna be able to
sleep tonight so that's just the way it
is don't worry about it
and i think it's the same thing coming
home you know it's like oh oh oh you're
gonna get you're gonna get sad sometimes
this doesn't mean you're weak it doesn't
mean you're uh trapped in the past it
just means you miss your friends and
that's okay and so if you are thinking
about something and it and it makes you
cry hey yeah that's what that's what
happens you know it's yeah that's the
way it is
and i think if people understand that
that that's
that that's normal
then they go oh okay well that's that's
just what's gonna happen it's okay
and i think when people don't think it's
normal and all of a sudden they think i
can't control my emotions or i'm scared
or um i'm sad and i shouldn't be sad and
i shouldn't be scared it's like no it's
fine no big deal that's just the way it
is you you do your job you you know
you're gonna be scared you got the you
got the queasy stomach you can't sleep
at night okay cool yeah guess what
there's a bunch of other guys that's not
not sleeping tonight either no big deal
no big deal oh you get home you you're
gonna feel sad you're gonna miss your
friends yeah we all miss them that's the
way it is that that's okay
and i think that helps people out a lot
to be able to just say oh okay what i'm
feeling
is not
an isolated thing it's just the way
human beings process
the the tough experiences that they go
through but you know
we both served in
the kind of service that
at one time
you didn't show that emotion yeah
and you weren't expected to
i think the service and a hope i've read
that they have i've seen
interviews that they have
that
now that's been taken consideration
it's okay to express
what you're feeling right now
it's okay to go seek counseling because
it's not going to end up on your officer
efficiency report
or your annual report or whatever report
you're going to get
and so i think
that
has been a great improvement with the
way we receive
uh our warfighting men and women
uh
especially those who have come back and
been engaged in combat
one thing i'll say uh
about the getting excited and and
nervous about the upcoming mission
and i would do the same thing in vietnam
i mean people said were you scared i
said well yeah i'm scared
but hey you know this is what we signed
up to do and this is it's what we're
going to do and a lot of times
i mean i've said that
trying to convince myself
but see i was a platoon commander i
couldn't sit there and tell my troops oh
my god i'm scared death or god ah i had
to put on
the show i had to do that
but the interesting thing about it is
once we strapped on that helicopter
and
we took off in flight all of that
drained
it all drained i mean it never amazed me
got a job to do
well yeah i mean you were busy you were
monitoring three radios you were you
know talking to the crew there
i mean it all drained i mean
even going into
even going into lola that morning when
we were doing 90 knots approaching we
should have been done 60 or 40 and we
were coming in there and
but you cycle that thing back in that
damn nose pitches up and you're saying
oh hell i hope my tail rudder doesn't
hit the ground and then you put that
sucker down and you're taking fire all
over the place
you don't have time to be scared
you you re
you react by the training that you've
had and by god that training was good
yeah yeah exactly and that's uh i think
the same way everybody feels i mean if
you're gonna be nervous it's usually
before an operation and for me i was
always just more nervous about my my
friends my guys that's what i was always
worried about hey i hope nothing happens
to guys you know uh but then once
for us it's once the breach goes you
know where once the once the breach goes
now it's on everybody knows we're here
we're doing what we're doing you know
once we leave the gate front gate you're
you're doing your job and there's
no time to think about that you can't
you can't waste any
mental capacity thinking about what
could happen or what might happen
because you got to do your job and you
don't want to have anything else in your
head besides hey what do i need to do
right now
how can i do my best job right now
that's what i'm thinking about
uh but again i seen some nervous new
guys
and just hey man it's all right no big
deal
and and i think that helps people a lot
just like anything anytime you can give
somebody a heads up about what's about
to happen or what i've had this feeling
with uh train training mma fighters
mixed martial arts fighters to go and
fight
and i saw the exact same thing this is
kind of where i started putting it
together oh i tell them hey oh your
stomach a little queasy yeah i'm super
nervous yeah you're supposed to be
you're getting ready to go into a fight
yeah it's okay and that would put them
at ease because they'd realize oh this
is just normal this is just me getting
ready to go into you know that form of
sporting combat
i think but but but to add to that i
think it's good to be a little nervous
for sure because you're more on your
game for sure